i'm here at stanford medical school with
morgan thies and dr laura bachrach and
they're going to
teach us some things
okay so what are we going to learn about
today i'd like to talk about
precocious puberty seems to be on the
mind of many parents these days
they worry that their child is
developing too early
they worry their child is going to be
too small as a result
they worry their child is going to get
picked on and they worry they might have
done something wrong fed the child the
wrong food or exposed them to the wrong
videos to cause this all to happen okay
so could we just
talk about what precocious puberty means
it almost sounds like they've done
something too soon is that is that
correct that's exactly true um the
normal process of puberty in a girl we
think
used we used to think started around the
age of 10 with a little bit of breast
development
and about six months later
the girls would get a little bit of
pubic hair
and around the age of 12 and three
quarters to 13 they'd get their first
period
okay
in boyce
we used to think the process was
starting a little later at about 11 and
a half
the boys would get some enlargement of
the testes
they'd get some pubic hair about a year
later
and by age 15 or so they'd be mature
we have a definition
of what's precocious
when there's signs of puberty before
eight in a girl
okay or before nine and a boy okay
so
eight or less less than eight in a girl
would be precocious and that's for the
breast development which happens first
any sign and puberty okay the breasts
the pubic hair or the periods would be
precocious if it happened before the age
of eight
in a girl
and in a boy
before the age of nine
now this has become a little bit
controversial
because there was one very large
pediatric study
that involved over 17 000 girls
that found that
as many as 25 percent of
african-american girls
would have a sign of puberty before
eight and as many as seven percent
of the white girls had some signs of
puberty for age eight but we're still
basically using these guidelines
not to say this is definitely abnormal
but this is something we're going to
evaluate if we see signs of puberty
before those age landmarks okay so it
sounds like there's a lot of variability
it's kind of hard to know on any
individual case
whether it's normal or not but we have
to have some kind of threshold for which
we're going to work someone ups make
sure that everything is normal you hit
on a really important word and that is
the variability and a lot of this
variability
uh is determined by genetics okay so
part of what we always need to know
is the timing of development in the
family
so when did mom get her first menstrual
period when did dad
get his puberty and growth spurt so
that's part of it is genetics and we
need to know that take that into account
if mom had her first period at 10 and
started her breasts at eight it may be
perfectly normal for her daughter if
mom's periods were at 14 and her
daughter has breast development at seven
and a half it's more worrisome okay okay
the second factor that seems to be
contributing potentially
is the over nutrition of our young
people oh yeah and in the particular
study that i mentioned to you where they
looked at over 17 000 children
at least for the white population they
could explain the earlier signs of
puberty
as an association with a high body mass
index
so it looked as if if you over nourish
your child you may speed along their
growth and eventually potentially speed
along
their onset of puberty i see now this
did not hold up
as an association in the
african-american population so there's
other factors going on there but that's
something that we take into account but
the bottom line is the child
may present with some signs of early
puberty
mom or dad get worried they go to the
pediatrician and the pediatrician has to
decide what's going on okay now just
backing up a little bit um
is this a problem i mean what's the
problem with say a seven-year-old girl
starting puberty um or
what are we gonna say like an
eight-year-old boy starting puberty
early i imagine there could be some
social implications as you mentioned but
what are sort of the things we worry
about well that's an important question
because it comes up not only how far do
we go to evaluate them but how far do we
go to treatment treat them so one of the
concerns parents have
relates to their final height okay so if
they start their growth spurt early in
life and close it off early in life are
they going to cheat themselves
out of some final height right so height
is a concern
okay and its impact really depends upon
how young the child is a three-year-old
going into puberty is definitely going
to end up short if we don't do something
okay a seven and a half year old girl is
probably not going to be altered by this
in terms of height a second concern is
definitely what you brought up in terms
of a social concern
parents worry the child may behave in an
older way or may be treated
in a way that they're not quite ready
for they may get unwarranted
attention from people because they look
older and there's even potential concern
for abuse sexual abuse right so those
are usually the parental concerns uh for
why they bring the child in the other
concern they have is
often what am i doing wrong there are a
lot of questions about should i have fed
my child organic food what about the
soap i was using what about the soap
operas my child was watching you know
they're really concerned about something
they might have done and they worry
about these additives in our plastics
and our teeth sealants etc they worry
about evils in our environment okay
so things that you address in in the
visit that you have with them are
definitely some of the the concerns that
parents inevitably have about what what
they could have done differently exactly
we start out
assessing in a sort of a systematic way
the first question we want to know is
when did this all start
and what did they notice and it's really
important to break down the signs of
puberty because different hormones
contribute to the different signs
for example in a girl if she's
presenting with some body odor some acne
and some pubic hair but no signs of any
breast development that leads us down
the road to worry about what we call her
androgens or male hormones
if a girl comes in with just breast
development
but none of the body hair or body odor
we think aha she's been exposed to
estrogens
and so we get a lot from the physical
exam in terms of thinking what hormones
to go after okay so even though the
definitions of precocious or just any of
these um you know different phases of
development happening too soon the
combination that you see is going to
direct what you think is going on with
them clinically exactly okay it'll make
us more or less worried and it will take
us down one avenue or another thinking
about what could be wrong
what level of abnormality in the hormone
system is at work okay can i ask a
question just
curious so what what are the most common
diagnoses that you give to people coming
in with their kids that are concerned
for precocious puberty the most common
diagnoses are variations on normal
there is a condition called
isolated premature adrenarchy which is a
fancy doctor way of saying the adrenal
glands producing their hormones we see
pubic hair underarm hair and acne
we also can see isolated breast
development in little toddler girls
that's not concerning
so that would just go away yeah
typically that begins between six months
and two years and goes away okay but
even within the more full-blown cases
where we're seeing
the breasts and the pubic hair in the
girl or the enlargement of the testes
and the pubic hair and the boy
where it's full on full-blown puberty
it may be
idiopathic or not pathological we think
that in girls
who develop fully
95 percent of the time
even if they have the full puberty
it's idiopathic or not pathological
whereas in boys about 50 percent of the
time there is pathology so the condition
is less common in boys but when it
occurs in boys it's more worrisome so
interesting okay
so it's less common for boys to have any
signs of precocious puberty but when it
does happen you worry more exactly
because it's most more likely to be
something bad exactly okay
okay
so i'm guessing as a endocrinologist
um
once you've sort of ruled out the normal
things then you start thinking more
about uh sort of what's going on in
terms of all the different hormones that
are controlling these things which maybe
is something that we'll talk about in a
different lecture exactly um is there
any other sort of general things that
you wanted to address when just talking
about
i think the general advice i would give
to a parent if if they see signs of
puberty um in their child
before ate in a girl before nine and a
boy they should at least question their
pediatrician about it
and the pediatrician should do a
complete exam
and the other factor that needs to be
looked at carefully is growth
because the child who's truly impurity
will have a growth spurt
so those are things that parents can be
aware of at home and i think it's
important
that the parent ask the pediatrician
about it
if they're concerned
okay well thank you so much